position for JoJo's hard kickoff last
night on The Bachelorette and Jojo
stopped by here today two differently
about everything and I mean everything
start with all those crazy first
impressions that keep getting more and
more deliciously cringe-worthy I got to
get right to the juicy stuff I'll say
watching those fellows arrive I mean the
first impressions that you must have had
because you had a unicorn you got a kill
you even had Santa Claus I think I had
it all last night yeah you know what I
like the guys that took a risk Santa
George or George speaking of first
impressions okay somebody who didn't do
anything outlandish was Jordan mm-hmm
and he definitely gave you the best
first impression yeah that that night
was so overwhelming did you know coming
into it that he was Jordan Rogers Aaron
Rodgers who is the famous quarterback
from the Brotherhood yeah he played NFL
himself yeah week before this whole
thing started I think his name got
leaked it was kind of all over the
internet so you know it's like Jordan
Rogers brother event so that's what I
knew going into it but I don't flower
the arrival yeah before I met him so I
knew just that tidbit about him but
nothing else are you dating
he can't answer these Wow Sarah Lee good
Jojo you're very good they did good with
it maybe a training I think you look
happy I'm happy this has been like one
of the most crazy last few months of my
life but amazing and it's been a
whirlwind of emotion you look fantastic
by the way last night yeah so I mean
obviously the guys were googoo gaga
did they give you a beauty team did they
give you wardrobe yeah so we have a
really great stylist on the show he
helped me we kind of we did before the
show we do fittings I could just pick
out the things that I loved the most and
we have a great makeup artist so they
they help me out every single day for
the most part during the season I did my
own hair like you know you always can do
your own hair the but the best I feel
like that's how I am do you think that
you really can find true love on reality
TV I fell in love with Ben not thinking
that it was gonna be possible
feel like you're completely over Ben
definitely over it and gosh the place
where I was ready to find that special
someone again yeah yeah find him we'll
have to tune it
give it one last try you could call it
dry